be sure that he sold the illusion of
access to his father
did you talk about the Biden brand what
does that mean
is the president compromised so Hunter
Biden's former best friend tight lips
with the media after talking to Congress
for hours today Devin Archer telling
lawmakers that the first son put then
Vice President Joe Biden on speakerphone
during business meetings over 20 times
Archer also saying that barisma added
Hunter to its board because of the Biden
brand Republicans calling the
questioning very productive
term he uses this
people would probably not be as in
trying to to legally lean on barisma
because of the binding plant which again
he's let's get rid of this is Joe Biden
the United States is compromised based
on Archer's testimony I think so I think
so Devin Archer himself said that was an
implication of of who the big guy is I
mean and and Archer talked about the big
guy and and how Hunter Biden always said
we need to talk to my guy when you see
when my guy is going to be here and
those types of things but former
impeachment manager now Congressman says
Joe's phone calls with his son were no
big deal and he seriously said they were
only talking about the weather
it was clear that that it was as part of
the daily conversations that Hunter
Biden had with his father President
Biden didn't even know who the people he
was at dinner he was just asked to say
hello uh and he would you know he
described what the weather was how uh
how what's going on on your end it's
kind of a Preposterous premise to think
that a father should not say hello to
people that the Sun or at dinner with
the son is at dinner with and that is
literally all the evidences
and then moments ago the White House
putting out a statement calling House
Republicans investigation
Democrats are throwing cold water on the
entire investigation
this investigation started during the
Trump Administration and they've come
forward with not one shred of evidence
tying President Biden to any of this I
don't have any concerns I think this is
a Witch Hunt
um if you know Hunter Biden has broken
the law he should be held accountable
for it you know I think that a lot of my
colleagues need to go back to school and
maybe go into the work of being the
because seemingly that's what they want
to do right now is play detective and
weaponize the government
well this is all something else and
Jesse before I came down I did some
research and I looked on all the other
networks websites and not a mention on
their home pages so if you're watching
here and you're watching the five you're
watching Fox News you're going to be in
the know the rest of the country maybe
not so much so the Democrats first said
this was Russia disinformation and now
they're saying yeah Joe Biden talked to
his son's business partners but it was
about the weather so we've made a lot of
progress over the last two and a half
years let me show you how this works a
country hires someone because their
father's vice president and then the guy
hangs out with the guys who hired him
and he's like you know what I'm going to
get the vice president on the phone vice
president talks to all the guys that
hired him and that's why they hired him
because he can get the vice president on
the phone you're selling access you're
selling influence that's the Biden
family business and it's been that way
for four decades now if you're saying
that Hunter and his father talk on the
phone every single day
well what happens the day after the
phone call he's on with the business
partners
so you put me on with a bunch of
Romanians yesterday while you were in
Bucharest
um why are you in Romania and who were
those guys
are we still pretending Biden has no
idea what's going on here they're
selling the Biden brand that's what
they're getting paid for and the Biden
brand according to Hunter was gold now
forget about the phone call for a second
okay the 20 phone calls how about all of
the dinners at Cafe Milano
you're saying he goes to dinners with
the Chinese the kazakhstanese the Greeks
the Romanians and and it's a dinner
where you sit down and you have an
appetizer an entree and they're talking
about weather the whole time
I mean you could do weather for about
five minutes but the whole dinner you
can't be all about weather also we find
from Devin Archer that yes Hunter was
hired to get Joe to fire the prosecutor
we also found out that Joe sits down
with a billionaire from Russia and then
a month later hunter gets a wire from
three and a half million dollars from
the Russian billionaire and then Hunter
flies with Joe on Air Force two to China
then a week later hunter gets millions
of dollars from the Chinese and then Joe
gets on the phone with the Chinese
business partners on speaker and then
Joe writes a letter of recommendation to
Brown University for the guy's daughter
but Joe has no idea what's going on
everywhere Joe Biden goes hunter gets
paid Joe goes to China hunter gets paid
he goes to Romania he gets paid
Kazakhstan gets paid Ukraine gets paid
we're not adding this thing up we're
still pretending Joe's not connected to
anything why does Joe Biden have six
different alien earliest email accounts
why does the family have 20 shell
companies why is this now a 50 million
dollar racket now you have two
eyewitness people testifying that Joe is
aware of what's going on you have IRS
whistleblower saying the thing was
corrupt and there was a cover-up you
have FBI whistleblowers saying the same
thing you have suspicious activity
reports you have offshore bank accounts
but the Democrats are like you know what
the Republicans still haven't really
made a connection between Joe and his
son's business okay okay if you also
forget about all the photographs the
voicemails the videos and the text
messages yeah then yes we have not made
that connection are they trying to
insult our intelligence no how dare they
if they only talked about the weather
Bill Clinton and Monica Lewinsky were
only playing Yahtzee all right Jeffrey
Epstein was just running an orphanage on
that island it no it it is funny because
to listen to that guy at Goldman that
idiot say that it's Preposterous no one
in their entire existence anybody who's
had a career has ever had an employee or
anybody call their dad in a meeting no
it's never happened it doesn't even I
don't even remember happening in high
school or college it's just the weirdest
thing but this is a guy that's what he
did for a living he made it rain using
his dad's influence I did learn one
thing that you shouldn't have friends
when you go into politics right because
they're going to turn on you they're
gonna there's like his close pal is
spilling the beans this is why I refuse
Jesse's friendship
he's going to turn on me
and the Democrats always focus on Trump
they compare him to the mafia remember
he talks like a mafia Dawn blah blah
blah and then you always find out that
whatever they accuse somebody of doing
it's what they're actually doing and of
course nobody ever talks you know
concretely about what they're going to
do in the mob they use you know I don't
know metaphors and little you know they
just don't say they're going to kill you
Katie although I thought about it this
is a pizza shop
yeah exactly but this is part of the
thing that we predicted that there would
be investigative ping pong the the Dems
were warned that everything you do to
Trump will be done to you because if you
have the power and you abuse it then if
there's going to be payback and it's
like it's like for as an American
citizen it's like you hired a mechanic
an electrician and a plumber to fix your
house and instead they're like arm
wrestling in the basement that's that's
what this is big up because you're just
going to have two two parties constantly
doing this until the end of time can the
Democrats keep up this
and like in their imagination can they
say that either Biden was truthful when
he said he never asked his son about his
business dealings or that two that they
were only talking about the weather in
all of the cases that Jesse was talking
about
I think the weather excuse and climate
change is a real problem that can get
you to 10 minutes
that's gonna go away that was what Dan
Goldman said about this I'm sure that
there was more than the weather
discussed but yeah we can keep it up as
long as it continues that nobody has a
piece of paper or a bank transfer or
something legit linking President Biden
the person we care about everyone I
don't know a single Democrat who defends
Hunter Biden or his character or
anything about it can I stop you there
because I rarely interrupt I know that
no that doesn't but I I was just
thinking about this like so when when
you get a commission uh position at the
White House and you go in to take your
your sign the ethical papers right one
of the things that you are asked to do
is to make sure that when you avoid a
conflict of interest yeah but also that
you avoid the appearance of a conflict
of interest and that's on the Vice
President Joe Biden at the time no
wonder President Obama was like let me
go with Hillary instead of this guy in
2016. well I think that it was a larger
issue obviously surrounding what Beau
Biden's death and that Joe Biden was not
in the right frame of mind to then go
mount a presidential campaign I agree
with you and this was a big issue in the
2020 primary remember Elizabeth Warren
really capitalized on this and said in
my white house we will have restrictions
that make it impossible for what
happened with the relationship between
Joe Biden and Hunter Biden with him
serving on Boards of foreign entities
which should be critical now I think
that I'm sure the same criticism would
be loved but it wouldn't get you to Joe
Biden is a mob boss and that's what
Republicans want I mean Tom emmer who's
the number uh three Republican it's
already been on TV says there's no piece
of paper connecting them Jim Jordan who
never met a microphone he didn't love
only said it was very productive why do
you think that is if you want to say
that Dan Goldman was you know out ahead
of his ski saying it was only the
weather Etc then explained to me when
they had hyped up this five million
dollar payment and Dan Goldman says on
air that Devin Archer had no idea about
it he was on the board of the company he
would absolutely know about something
like that and that he may have been on
the phone but they didn't discuss his
business dealings insofar as him being
involved
but you're not going to but look at it I
have to read this here because we just
set this in from Devin Archer's Council
so they put out a statement and it says
this we are aware that all sides are
claiming Victory following Mr Archer's
voluntary interview today but all Devin
Archer did was exactly what we said he
would do show up and answer the
questions but to him honestly and
completely Mr Archer shared the truth
with the committee and we will leave it
to We Believe to them and other to
decide what to do with it Katie I'll
give you the last word we're going to
see these transcripts from this so
people can read through them and come up
with their own opinion about who won and
who lost what the victories were but
what we know based on today you know Dan
Goldman is usually a pretty forceful
attorney and if you're watching you at
least think that he's making a
compelling argument blaming the weather
is not a compelling argument who's also
very nervous he was very sweaty and for
years we've asked this question okay
what was Hunter Biden's business what
was he doing when he went to China or
serving on the board of barisma getting
paid eighty thousand dollars a month
what was the actual Biden business
because they said it was legitimate
right it wasn't a fair violation we
learned today that the Biden family
business was helping verisma with their
brand and that included Vice President
Joe Biden when the prosecutor was
investigating them for corruption when
brisma wanted to come into the United
States and do business here with their
initial public offering they needed and
were pressuring pressuring Hunter Biden
with his father mother to get rid of the
prosecutor that happened we also have
the dinners it's not just the phone
calls that they had there's all these
photos of all these people together and
so moving forward on the heels of Hunter
Biden's plei deal falling apart as a
result of this blanket immunity that
they tried to get in there on the
Pharaoh charges
these Fair charges are connected to
Hunter Biden but based on the brand that
was connected to Joe Biden with barisma
how could they not be right and if you
want to talk about the money and all of
that there's a reason why the F the FBI
document the 1023 says that they were
going to run through it all these bank
accounts or take 10 years to find that
you have the oversight committee saying
the same thing they did this in an
untraceable fashion including working
with Russian oligarchs to allegedly
you know the launder money so there's
more to this and a lot of the testimony
from Archer today also connected to
other people that the committee can now
interview I just say really quickly and
for maybe the 80s time Victor shoken was
not fired to protect Hunter Biden it had
the opposite effect there are so many
articles there's Senator Ronson articles
well yes that's how things get
documented like in the pressures
the IMF we do right yeah what all right
we do is
on its way we already got started but
influencers can't get enough of Joe
Biden at the beach as the
commander-in-chief takes another
vacation I winner Brian Kilmeade I want
you to do me a favor I want you to click
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page this is is the only way that I know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now